I'm going to talk about where the
chemical elements come from if you want
something close to a symbol I'm going to
talk about the art process and the s
process we're going talk about chemical
elements which means I need to venture
alarmingly close to chemistry and
actually talk a little bit about the
periodic table so first let me show you
an astronomers periodic table which is
this there are only three things in the
universe as far as astronomers are
concerned there's hydrogen helium and
everything else which we tend to call
metals and the fraction of each we tend
to call x y&z I'm only showing this
because it really annoys chemists but
actually to a large extent it's sort of
helpful because actually one of the
things that astronomers broadly know is
that hydrogen and helium were mainly
made in the Big Bang and everything else
was more or less made in stars you do it
by mass it's about three-quarters
hydrogen one quarter helium and a tiny
bit of everything else a few percent of
everything else so these are not to
scale in that sense all right but it
turns out astronomers do no actually
know a bit more about chemical elements
and where they come from up from there
and in fact there's a very nice graphic
that appeared a little while ago that
tries to summarize it it's caused quite
a lot of discussion and debate in this
national local community but at least to
a first approximation it kind of tells
you what's going on and it sort of
reflects the story that I've just told
you that hydrogen and helium were made
in the Big Bang and pretty much
everything else was made in stars now it
turns out of course that that's not true
when you start looking in detail at
things so for example when you start
looking at all the very heavy elements
which have very short lifetimes the only
way we can actually make that is by
making them ourselves specially made in
stars has long since decayed away so the
very heavy elements are actually
human-made rather than star made and
actually it turns out when you look at
the light end of things things are a
little more complicated as well because
you've got things like lithium and
beryllium you've got little C's next to
them here they're actually made through
a process called cosmic ray spallation
cosmic rays are these very high-energy
particles whizzing through space and
when when a very high-energy particle it
could be an atomic nucleus whacks into
another particle could be another atomic
nucleus that you can actually have
phishing occurring that the atomic
nuclei can fall apart so something which
was initially a heavier element can
actually be splattered into these little
bits we believe the main way that
lithium and beryllium and boron get made
is through that spallation process so
they weren't actually made in stars well
at least something heavy was probably
made in a star but then it got smashed
to pieces through cosmic ray
interactions the broad story is that
hydrogen helium made in the Big Bang
then you have stars stars in their
center few
use lighter elements to heavier elements
because that's how they power their
fusion-powered and so you can make
heavier elements one of the main ways
you make heavy elements is in the core
of a star when you've got hydrogen
turning into helium and helium turning
into carbon and so on but that kind of
gives out at iron because once you get
to iron then making heavier things by
smashing iron nuclei together it turns
out that absorbs energy rather than
giving energy out so you stop getting
energy out of the process when you get
to iron and of course if you're trying
to power a star you need to get energy
out so stars give up once they get to
iron and so again the simple law in in
astronomy is hydrogen and helium came in
the Big Bang everything up to iron was
made in the Centers of stars and then
everything heavier than iron only gets
made in supernovae because when a star
explodes then you have lots of energy
around and you can have these very
inefficient processes you're not trying
to power a star any more so actually you
can smack things together and create the
heavier elements like gold and all
heavier things that are around get made
in supernovae and if you look at this
plot that's kind of true in that if you
just look at it so we've got the green
and the yellow and stuff that's made in
stars and you can see all the lighter
elements as we go down the periodic
table tend to be green in nature till we
get to about iron and then they sort of
start turning more to this pinky orange
color which is super novae and so you
can see the more mass of elements tend
to get made in in supernovae but
interestingly it's not entirely true
it's not like everything stopped at iron
and then suddenly everything is made in
supernovae and in particular if you look
at these guys here it's not gonna have
to struggle with my command of the
periodic table and chemistry in general
that's barium lanthanum and cerium you
can see they're actually made in stars
but they're way heavier than iron right
iron somewhere way up here and these are
what down towards the bottom of the
periodic table and so the question is
how on earth do you end up with these
heavy elements which clearly aren't made
in supernovae but are actually are made
in star somewhere on the line and that's
where we get to this thing called the
art process and the s process it's
actually quite hard to make a heavy
element because you have to take so if
you're going to make a heavy element
through fusion you've got to take two
fairly heavy nuclei and smack them
together and get them to stick and heavy
nuclei have quite large charges
associated with them so you know
hydrogen only has one unit one proton
but by the time you get to these heavier
elements they have to have lots of
protons so they have lots of positive
charge lots of positive charge so
actually they repel each other very
effect
so it's very hard to make heavy elements
just by smacking nuclei together turns
out there's an easier way to make
heavier elements which is that if you've
got a neutron neutral particle then you
kind of make that stick to a nucleus so
you basically smack it into a nucleus
it'll stick and that'll add to the
weight of the nucleus now you haven't
actually changed the chemical at that
point because so chemicals that the
chemical properties of something depend
on how many protons there are in it not
how many neutrons are in it so adding a
neutron to it just changes the isotope
of the chemical it doesn't actually
change the chemical but neutrons can
then decay through a process called beta
decay and then their Neutron basically
turns into a proton and kicks out an
electron and a neutrino in the process
so you sneaked a proton in there by the
backdoor
exactly without having to overcome these
cool and repulsions I've been and
managed to sneak an extra particle in
which then magically turns into a proton
so I've changed the element that way so
it turns out that's actually the main
way you make these heavy elements is
just by adding neutrons and in a
supernova there's loads of neutrons
around huge Neutron flux cuz there's a
lot of everything around here supernovae
it's a complete mess and so you can have
a nucleus and you can just basically
bombard a whole load of neutrons into it
and then it'll end up a very heavy
isotope of whatever it started with but
then those neutrons will go Bing Bing
Bing Bing Bing and will be to decay down
into protons so you can end up creating
heavier elements that way and that works
great you can actually you know it
decays once and that moves it one place
up the periodic table because you added
a proton effectively and then it decays
again and so you can kind of walk your
way up the periodic table that way the
problem is that sooner or later in that
process you'll reach a stable isotope
one which will just stay there forever
so it will decay for a while and then
it'll stick and that means that anything
kind of further upstream from that
nucleus you can't make any more because
it you've got stuck at that point where
it's actually it's you know everything's
decayed as far as it's going - nothing
else is going to happen to it after that
so what I've just described as a thing
called er process or standing for rapid
because you added a whole bunch of
neutrons very rapidly now there are
other chemicals that exist in the
universe that are kind of blocked by
this process that they wouldn't actually
form from this process and the only way
you can make those is through this thing
called the s process which is the slow
process which is that you add a neutron
you wait for it decay it turns into a
proton it changes it and then you add
another Neutron and you wait for decay
and it
into the next element up and that way
you you don't have this kind of blocking
effect because you can always just add
another Neutron and then it'll decay and
so on so through that process you can
get to a whole other set of elements
through this thing called the s process
that don't get made through the art
process but you can you know there are
other decay chains that will get you to
these s process elements but in a
supernova everything happens very
quickly right because you've got this
massive neutron flux and then it's all
over and you know hours so you only get
one go to add on you exactly and these
decays if you do this s process you know
you add it you add a neutron sometimes
these decays can take weeks months years
thousands of years and so actually
you're never going to that s process is
never going to work in a supernova
because you've added one and by the time
it's the cage to the next thing along
the whole supernova is over and so
you're not going to add any more
neutrons and so things which you made
through this s process can't be made in
supernovae so we have to look somewhere
else where there is this process where
you can add neutrons to things but over
a much longer period of time
tens years hundred years thousands of
years rather than all in one go and it
turns out that in the late stages of
some stars lives they actually produce
quite a lot of free neutrons some of the
late stage burning things so when you're
burning carbon into heavier elements or
Nijo you actually get liberate quite a
few neutrons along the way and so there
are free neutrons over the hundreds of
thousands of years that the star is
going through this phase of its life
time kind of bending around within the
star which means that you can actually
then over time add neutrons through
these s process these elements here that
I was talking about before barium
lanthanum cerium only made through this
s process and that means that the only
way they can possibly be made is that it
was probably from previous generations
of stars there was a fairly heavy
element in the in the star like iron or
something like that which then had a
late in the lifetime of the star had
these this sort of free Neutron flux
bumping into it over tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of years which
would through this s process turn it
into one of these heavier elements like
barium it's quite interesting that that
whenever you you know whenever you get
get some barrier you know pretty much
how that has to reform then it's
actually quite a long story this is a
rods of barium week one here that there
must have been the first generation of
stars that went supernova throughout
lots of heavy elements
that will produce through this our
process but that wouldn't have made the
barium then some of those heavy elements
were then incorporated into a later
generation of stars late in the lifetime
of that particular star there was a
strong one Neutron flux within the star
which would then through these s process
get it up to these these heavy elements
like barium and lanthanum quite a
journey some of those atoms have been on
it really is and I you know it's kind of
astounding that just by sort of
understanding the nuclear physics and
how these various chemical elements get
made you can actually trace you know
when you've got one of these elements
you can actually look at it and say well
I know how this must have formed and
it's quite as you say it's a quite a
long and involved story in some of these
elements we should be able to file a
little bit of the barium onto this foil
oh my can see little bits coming off
actually they're very very small